welcome to clean testing
i'm jason taylor an ssw solution
architect you can find me on twitter
at jasontaylordev recently i've been
teaching folks about clean architecture
and i've highlighted the simplest
approach to enterprise application
development with
net core tonight in this talk i want to
demonstrate a simple
and yet powerful approach to automated
testing with
net core i want to demonstrate an
approach where tests are easy to create
maintain and understand and give you the
confidence to deploy to production
knowing that it will behave as expected
let's get started
so we'll we'll kick it off with an
introduction to clean architecture and
following that i'm going to provide an
overview
of clean testing next we'll take a quick
look at testing frameworks and tools
and then we'll jump right into the live
demos and this is where we're going to
spend most of our time it's going to be
a lot of fun
i had a lot of fun putting this talk
together i think you're going to really
enjoy it
finally i'm going to wrap it up with a
quick summary and some resources in case
you're keen to learn more
so with clean architecture the domain
and the application layer
at the center of the design this is
known as the core of the system
now the domain layer contains enterprise
logic and types
whereas the application layer contains
business logic and types
the difference being that enterprise
logic could be shared across multiple
systems
whereas the business logic is the logic
that's specific to the system
if you've heard my talks before on clean
architecture you know that i often use
northland traders as an example
so an example of business logic in
northwind traders would be create an
order
or create a customer or update a
customer those sorts of things
so now core should not be dependent on
data access concerns and other
infrastructure so those dependencies are
inverted
so infrastructure and presentation
depend on core
this is achieved by adding interfaces or
abstractions
within core that are implemented outside
of core
a good example is messaging if we wanted
to have some sort of messaging
capability within core
then we could say add an interface i
messaging service
and ins outside of core inside of
infrastructure we could add an
implementation
now it doesn't actually matter what that
implementation is at that point all of
our business logic that we include
inside core
can just run against the interface we
can change that implementation
say from twilio to sendgrid to a local
smtp server
anything we want and as long as that
messaging interface doesn't change
our business logic is not impacted by
that
so you can see that all dependencies
flow inwards and core has no
dependencies on any other layers
now infrastructure and presentation both
depend on core
but not on one another and that's very
important if
as an example we had presentation
depending on core
because i wanted to access that
messaging service well then that would
be
a dependency on a concrete
implementation
which would be not great because we
couldn't change that implementation
would be fixed
in using that in presentation but also
it would mean that we'd have to put
logic in presentation to orchestrate
that interaction
the interaction between say for example
on asp.net controller
and the messaging service that we're
using so we want those dependencies to
always point inwards so that we can keep
the logic
within core
so this results in an accurate texture
and design that is independent of
frameworks it doesn't require
the existence of some framework it's
testable and that's why we're here
tonight
i'm going to show you a very simple and
powerful approach to testing systems
that that implement these principles of
clean architecture
it's independent of the ui so right now
we might be using an angular application
soon we'll change it to view and next
view we'll change it to blazer for sure
it's independent of the database right
now it's using sql server we've tested
it with postgres
we might use the cosmos db in the future
it's independent of anything external
so in fact core just doesn't know
anything at all about the outside world
and that's what makes this design so
great it's the difference between
something that's going to last three
years
and something that will be still around
in 20 years now that's quite a brief
introduction
but i do have this video that if you'd
like to learn more you can check this
out
this is my clean architecture with
asp.net course free otalk
that was recorded in ndc sydney last
year
so certainly worth a look if you're new
to the topic of clean architecture
so now we get to have a look at clean
testing that's why we're here
so first i want to look at the typical
approach to testing
with the typical approach to automated
testing the focus is on
unit tests integration tests
and ui tests no surprises there so we
know that ui tests are the most
expensive to create
and they're also the slowest to run so
we therefore try to minimize the amount
of ui tests we create
in the middle we've got integration
tests and then at the bottom we've got
unit tests and we know that unit chests
are cheap to create
and faster on so this is where we're
going to focus the majority of our
efforts
so generally we're going to try to write
a unit test first
if we can't write a unit test then we'll
move up the pyramid and write an
integration test
and finally if this particular piece of
behavior cannot be integration tested
then we'll write a ui test so for some
examples
if logic exists in an angular front-end
then we need to write a ui test
we could of course use a variety of
different javascript testing frameworks
to do that
but for me i consider that to be a ui
test next if logic exists in the asp.net
core controller for example then we need
to write some sort of asp.net core
integration test
fortunately asp.net core has really good
tools for that so it's not so bad
but the thing with the clean
architecture approach that we're taking
is we're keeping the logic completely
out of presentation
so that includes angular or vue or or
react and that includes our web api our
web api is
very simple just infrastructure and so
we're not going to be looking at writing
tests in those areas
so what we will be doing is focusing on
subcutaneous tests so with clean testing
we'll introduce subcutaneous
tests into the mix and we'll still write
unit integration and ui tests
but the main focus is going to be on the
subcutaneous testing
and that's because these tests are the
ones that are easy to write
and run these tests effectively verify
behavior and integration
they document the system and they reduce
the need to create
and maintain a large number of mocks and
if you've if you've if you've built a
lot of hand rolled mocks or even used a
great mocking tool like mq
sorry mock you then you know that that
can be
a real pain it can be time consuming and
that can be a little bit fragile
so in short these tests these
subcutaneous tests are going to provide
us with a great deal of confidence
so now i know you're asking what are
subcutaneous tests
so subcutaneous tests are tests that
operate
just below the ui layer now we talked
about this a little bit but i just want
to touch on it again because this can be
confusing
so for a single page application if it
was view with an asp.net
web api backend then just below the ui
layer
could be below the view layer and that
would be appropriate
if we have logic inside of asp.net or
controllers
or endpoints or somewhere along those
lines we could write subcutaneous tests
to in
to to operate at that point but again
with this clean architecture
that i provide we're not putting any
logic in that layer so we get to operate
one layer below
so we'll we'll look at what that layer
will be shortly
so with subcutaneous tests we're going
to verify the basic
inputs and outputs of the system and
this provides good test coverage and
helps to ensure that tests are not
brittle
these tests are only appropriate if you
keep your logic out of the ui i think i
think i probably hopped on that enough
so
um and this will therefore reduce the
need for ui tests which is a good thing
because we know as we mentioned earlier
they're expensive to create
and they're brittle they're also slow
so let's have a look at this from a
slightly different perspective
so presentation in this layer diagram
contains the ui
for a typical spa that might be the view
front-end combined with the web api
back-end
or for a microservice it might just be a
web api back-end depending on your
approach of course
we have core which includes the
application and domain layers
and that contains all logic it includes
commands queries validators
cross-cutting concerns
anything else you can think of that
you've got inside of core
infrastructure represents both our
internal and
external infrastructure so an example of
internal infrastructure might be the
database that we're programming against
and and keep in mind these tests will
run against a live database
um an example of external infrastructure
might be the external client api
so the subcutaneous tests are going to
operate just below
the presentation layer operating all the
way through core
and the internal infrastructure so the
live database and so
we're going to actually wire up services
for these tests we're going to wire up a
production
system to be as close to production as
possible so to ensure that we're
definitely on the same page
what we're going to be testing is our
commands and queries so in the clean
architecture approach that i demonstrate
the logic is moved out of the front end
out of presentation
and into commands and queries inside of
core in the application layer and those
are the entry points for our application
so we'll include internal services so
we're going to wire up things like
our live database we're going to wire up
asp.net identity and any other services
that we're using in production
but we'll mock our external services so
if there's something such as
an external client api that we're
talking to we didn't create that
um we don't maintain it and it's kind of
um it can be a little bit fragile
to run that as part of our automated
test because we don't know if it's going
to be up
it's going to be down or how it's going
to behave so we'll mock those external
services and we really want to minimize
the amount of mocks that we write just
keep it down to hopefully just a small
few
because that's going to make our test
give us all the more confidence
so we want to keep it simple of course
we want these tests to be easy to write
and maintain because that's that's the
approach that we're trying to build here
so with that definition out of the way
let's have a look at testing tools
i want to kick it off with the
frameworks that i considered when i was
trying to put together the approach to
clean testing
so first and foremost i looked at end
unit it's a popular choice for many.net
and
net core developers and it's probably
the most widely used
next we have x unit now this is by far
the most popular choice
for net core and it's also used by a
number of teams at microsoft
in fact it's probably one of my
favorites then we have
ms test now if you've seen my
presentations before
you know that i love building logos for
for ms tests they don't have a logo
this is my latest version i've used
microsoft emojis this time
so i think it's much more professional
than my last version i hope you enjoy it
so i think ms test can be somewhat of a
default choice for many new developers
and and i think that a lot of the time
they'll move on to nu and x unit one
other framework that i looked at was
fixy and this is a powerful
conventions-based framework
and the reason that i looked at this
particular framework is because it was
recommended
by jimmy bogard in an article
integration
tests with x unit and he basically
described that
you have to jump through a few hoops if
you want to write integration text in x
unit you can do it
but it's not simple and he suggested
that something like fixy or other
behavior during design frameworks can be
much much better so i wanted to check
that out for myself
and i really did like fixie in fact i
built a um fixie.net call project
template so if you want to write some
tests in fixer you can check out the.net
core project template
so i didn't have time to try out all of
these because for three of them
i wrote a lot of subcutaneous tests so
that i could choose the right framework
but i didn't use ms test maybe i should
have
they put a lot of work into ms test i
know it's been
cross-platform for a while now it's out
of the box with
net core it's fast um so maybe that's an
exercise for next time
but for this particular exercise i
looked at end unit x unit and fix c
and um i guess you know the the thing
was i had to decide which framework was
best for me
so which framework did i go with before
this i had been programming with x unit
and while it's possible to create great
subcutaneous tests in any one of these
frameworks
i decided to run with n unit and the
reason for this
was for this style of testing i found
n-unit to provide the best support
it was simple it actually seemed to run
a little bit faster for my tests
i didn't actually benchmark that so i
can't say that with authority
but that was the feeling i was getting
they were running faster and it had
great
mechanisms for managing global shared
state when we're writing
subcutaneous tests and we're trying to
wire up these production scenarios
obviously that's really important
so end unit one so next
some tools let's have a look at first
and foremost fluent assertions
this tool contains a large set of
extension methods
that allow you to more naturally specify
the outcome of your test
and it also improves the readability
within your tests so that makes your
tests easier to understand and that's
one of the goals of this approach
tests should be easy to create and
maintain
not only that one of the greatest things
about fluent assertions is it clearly
explains test failure results you get
better test results
and as a result of that it means you
need to do less debugging
so how many times do you if i have a
test failure and you immediately launch
the debugger set a breakpoint and try to
figure out what's going on
i find that i'm actually doing that less
and less with fluent assertions
because the the better test results that
it's providing means that i can see
immediately
what's going wrong and how i can fix it
so i can jump straight into you know
fixing that red moving onto green and
refactoring
so overall i found that fluent
assertions improved my productivity
and simplified my approach it's a great
tool you should check it out
you might be using should we have used
should we in the past i think it's good
too
but i'm certainly enjoying switching it
up with fluent assertions
okay and next we have mock i don't think
it needs much of an introduction
but just in case it's the
mockingframeworkfor.net
i think it's a default choice for many
developers now according to the repo
it's very popular and friendly now i can
confirm that it's indeed popular
but i don't agree that it's friendly
it's never once greeted me in the
morning it's never given me any
compliments
it's never said how nice and clean my
code is which i take a lot of time to
try and make it nice and clean
but it is popular it is probably the
number one choice for mocking frameworks
that aside it does support mocking
classes and interfaces
and it's strongly typed so there's no
magic strings
it's simple to use with no prior
knowledge required you can really do
a lot with mock just by having a look at
its fluent syntax
so next we have respawn so this is my
favorite new tool
respawn is an intelligent database
cleaner for integration tests
and just in case we're you're wondering
what respawn is
um it's it's uh what the word means of
course
it means that um it's kind of like when
you're playing a video game let's say
you're playing um
quake and you die and then your
character respawns and you can continue
on to quite another day
so it's kind of like that for databases
it wipes the database to a clean state
you've got all your health back
and you're ready to go again ready to
run that next test already to get that
next frag
so what it does is instead of deleting
data or rolling back transactions it
takes a performant approach
by working out the relationships and
deleting the data in the correct order
respawn is easy to configure you can set
it to ignore tables and schemas such as
the ear
migrations history table and i'm going
to show you that
because if we're resetting the database
to clean state that means wiping the
data obviously we can't
wipe the ef migrations history table
otherwise it's going to be out of sync
with ef core
so now it supports many databases such
as sql server postgres
mysql i predominantly work with sql
server so i've only
used it with sql server at this stage
the cool thing
about respawn is it's small and it's
easy to learn
so i'm going to show you a lot in this
talk but if you'd like to learn more of
course you can go and check out the
the repo so now the best part of the
talk we can move on to the live demos
all of these demos are going to be run
using the clean architecture solution
template
so this is something that i actually
built for my talk for nbc sydney
last year and it was based on everything
that i'd learned
in talking to people about clean
architecture presenting
clean architecture and teaching clean
architecture so it's a
net core template package you basically
run.net and uci solution
and you get a bunch of projects out of
the box ready to go it runs asp net core
angular 9 energy framework core 31 and
asp net core identity
so if you wanted to try it out you just
simply install it from the command line
dot net new install clean architecture
solution template
and then you can create a new project by
going dot net new ca
solution and it will create that project
for you of course you can learn a lot
more at the repo and
i've got a link to that repo at the end
of this presentation
but this is what we're going to be using
for the demos tonight the only
difference is
i've deleted the tests
okay so let's begin demo on clean
testing we're going to create tests that
are easy to write
and maintain with end unit balloon
assertions mock and respawn
okay what i'd like to do
is start with a little bit of a
demonstration so we're going to talk
about
what we're going to be testing uh a
quick overview of the project first
so when you run this new ca solution
what you get out of the box is a single
page application
built on angular with asp.net core back
end
adhering to the principles of clean
architecture
and so just briefly it contains four
projects
the domain and application layers making
up core
the infrastructure layer and the
presentation layer which is called web
ui
so that's exactly what you saw on the
diagram now i don't want to go into too
much detail here because you can see
that in the other presentation
we'll spend our time talking about clean
testing now the template also comes with
i think three test projects so really
good examples of tests um
straight out of the box including these
subcutaneous tests that we're going to
be writing tonight
so i have a little bit of functionality
in here and we're going to be testing
that this is my to-do list
um sample and it's basically multiple
lists
and multiple to-do items with various
capabilities for managing items
and managing lists and creating lists
and creating items a little bit of fun
working with it
so i created this much earlier in the
year and i thought i'll create a covert
19 shopping list and of course it was
easy to get apples milk and bread
but i wasn't able to yet check toilet
paper pasta tissue's tuna and water off
the list i think i had to meet
the shady guy at the end of my street
who had stocked up on these things
so let's write some tests i think we
need to look at
writing a simple test first and so we'll
write a test for
get to do's and that's what this view is
driven by it's driven by a view model
called the to-do's view model
so let's give that a test so in the
application layer
i have this to-do list folder and inside
of there i have a queries folder
and inside of there i have a get to do's
folder so let's have a look at this get
to this query so hopefully this is nice
and big for you
or make it even bigger so the way this
query is structured
is it has a dto for the query request
and this might contain parameters to
pass in as part of the
the request so it might include some
filtering options
some paging options and sorting options
whatever it is that we we wanted to
include
when we wanted to get a list of to-do's
in this case i really just want
everything
and i don't need to provide any
arguments
for this particular query now just below
that
in the same file i have this get to do's
query handler
and this contains the logic for building
the to-do's view model
and essentially what it does is it
returns a today's view model
which consists of a number of priority
levels and
to-do lists and each to-do list is made
up of a to-do list dto
and a to-do list dto contains a number
of items to do item dto
so we're going to start writing some
tests for
this one what did i change there
oh of course yep
okay so first we're going to create a
new project
so i'm going to create it in this test
folder and i'll go
add new project and of course as i
mentioned we're using end unit
so we're going to use an end unit test
project in net core
go next and we will call it
clean testing
dot uh
integration and we'll call it
cleantesting.application.org integration
test because this is going to target our
application layer i could also call it
subcutaneous test
i might even change that at some point
we're creating that just waiting
i always like to run the default test
just to make sure everything's
um working we'll just make sure that
we've got those dependencies restored
take a second this is all getting
cleaned up
when i'm not recording and presenting
live it takes about one second
when we're recording and presenting live
i'm pretty sure that just took ten
minutes of my time
so anyway we're there now we'll run that
so i just went ctrl rt nice little
shortcut to run this particular test
and we'll switch to test explorer it's
just doing a quick build
i'll just expand that out
there's absolutely no reason why this
test wasn't wrong but hopefully
it'll warm up my surface book and make
the rest of the presentation go a little
bit faster
maybe not it's time to get a new laptop
okay that's all good so we don't need
that test so we'll go ahead and delete
that
and we're going to create our new test
so
let me see i will use my
little snippets and i have a cool little
extension
called add new file you probably heard
me talk about it before it allows me
just to specify the full path
including folders to be created and the
file name
a folder structure and a file name
that replicates the folder structure and
file names that are in the application
layer
so now my application layer is neatly
organized and so on my tests
so i've got this little nice test ready
to go
now i'm going to grab my stub for that
test
and looks good
we'll need to bring in some name spaces
so we'll bring in end unit
we'll bring in a reference now i want to
add a reference for this project
to web ui so you might be thinking why
is he adding a reference to web ui why
not to
application layer that's what we're
testing we'll remember we're going to
set up the production scenario
and in web ui is where we have
startup.cs
and then startup.cs is where we
configure our services
and we want to reuse that functionality
so i'm just going to go ahead and add a
reference to web ui
and of course web ui has an application
a reference to application
anyway
so now i'll hit control dot
and we won't do that yet just wait for
it to find its reference
check make sure i didn't do anything
wrong
testing with your
yeah that's it okay good so now we've
fixed up pretty much all of the
references oh we need to install some
packages as well so we're going to
install
fluent assertions mock and respawn
why don't we just do that from the
command line because it'll be a little
bit quicker
drag that up here
that's slow okay so dot net
add oh there's auto complete we'll use
that right now order
dotnet add package fluent assertions
and we want mock
moq i should have just pasted this into
the cs project that'd be a little bit
quicker
this is fun too
and respawn
there we go okay we'll let that
disappear
this one should appear here and we'll be
able to fix up those
references
yay okay good so back to the code that
we're working on
so we just need to bring in fluent
assertions
good
almost didn't do it
try it again there we go
and we'll just clean up those name
spaces
so that looks good that's what i want to
be this is the test that i want to write
of course
it's not going to run right now i
haven't wired up the database i haven't
wired up any production services
this little helper method doesn't exist
and so a little bit of an explanation on
this helper method so
in the application layer i'm using a
tool called mediator
and with mediator all of my commands and
queries are defined as requests
and i can say mediator.send and i can
give it a query or a command essentially
a request
and it'll find the handler that's
associated with that request we saw an
example of that just now
and then it will return the response and
so we want to send
we want our tests to run through
mediator and there's a really important
reason for that because of course
we could just test the commands and
queries directly
and we could actually just unit test
them we don't need to write subcutaneous
tests for them
but when we're using mediator i have
these behavior pipelines set up
so here's an example here's a validation
behavior
every request that comes through the
system runs through mediator
and mediator will automatically validate
any request so it will just basically
say hey if this request has any
validators
then validate it and if there are any
failures then throw a validation
exception
so we want this to be part of our test
we want to test this whole pipeline we
want to test as much of the production
scenario
as possible and so we definitely want to
pass it through mediator
here's another one is an unhandled
exception behavior will automatically
log any unhandled
exceptions for any requests so we've got
a few other examples there
so let's go back down here so really
what we need to do now
is to wire up our production services
and to
implement this helper method um
but we also don't want to be dependent
on global data for a couple of reasons
um if we were writing our test this way
we're assuming that that there is only
one list
and that there are only six items in
that list but this is coming this data
is coming from somewhere and typically
when you see this
that means it's coming from some sort of
global location
but of course someone's going to need to
change that data at some point to suit
the needs of another test
and of course that's going to break a
whole bunch of tests so it would be much
better if we could set up the data that
we need
right here as part of this test and then
of course we have this new tool respawn
which is going to clean up the database
each time so we'll have a clean state
for each test
so i've got a little snippet we can
throw in we'll grab that
there it is and so here it is so we're
calling add async
and we're passing in a to-do list with a
bunch of to-do items so a nice little
shopping list
i'll bring in the name space for that
you can see that async hasn't been
implemented yet because it's another
helper method
it's basically going to allow me to pass
an object graph
and it'll try to add it using entity
framework called db context
then we can run we can set up our query
we can take an action
so we can send the query get the result
and then assert on that result
so let's go to the next steps of getting
that test to actually run
so what i'll do first is i'm going to
create a testing.cs class
and this testing.cs class is going to be
responsible
for wiring up those services and also
exposing some helper methods so we've
seen ad async
and we've seen send async and we're
going to add a few more along the way
so we're going to use some of
n units great mechanisms for
managing global test setup
so we have the setup fixture bringing
that
and this one time setup so this is going
to run for everything in this
namespace which is kind of the root name
space for this
this project it's going to run this one
time
and so we can use this to wire up our
services set up our
database and to set up respawn so we'll
leave that for the moment
now i also want to create stubs for
those helper methods
and so i'm going to put them just in
here
i need to fix this up before that bites
me
look at that i'm fixing my own arrows
tonight this is going to be great
that one that one and
i'll come back to that because i want to
paste this in
there we go we'll come back to here pop
that one up the top
hit control x i don't think we need to
think about that
okay and control d
okay that's looking better
clean it up okay so
yes we need to bring a mediator
and i think that's it
so we've got our helper methods ready um
what's it complaining about it
lacks a lack of weight that's okay um
we'll come back to that so we've got the
stubs for our two helper methods add
async and send async
and we've got this one-time setup which
we can use to set up our services in our
database
so if we want to now use these helper
methods of course we could say
testing.adasync because they're static
and we can access them that way but we
can actually
use the using static director which is
really cool
and if we say using static testing um
then it's actually going to allow us to
access those members without specifying
testing all throughout here
so you can see those squigglies are gone
immediately and knows where to find them
so we're going to see this appear in all
of our test classes
and that's going to expose our helper
methods
so why don't we come back here
and start wiring this up
um so the first thing that i want to do
is wire up configuration i'm going to
need a couple of things i'm going to
need configuration
and that's going to be used to wire up
our services
so i'm going to just steal from web ui
our app.settings and i'll still
the whole lot because we'll need
something from dev as well
i'll just drag that in there
okay so i won't need anything from
production so
delete that from development i want
this configuration for identity server
it basically says that um
it's running in development and we don't
need to wire up an ssl or anything like
that
so i've got that in clipboard and so
then we'll go to app settings
and i can put that in here
and now i just want to change my oh my
that should actually not be like that
let's change that because i'm going to
commit all of this code for you
at the end um so that you can see the
demo so that one should be our clean
testing database
and this one is our very much separate
clean testing test database
starting to get confusing but anyway
that's all we need for configuration
um one of the features that you that
that you'll notice in the clean
architecture solution template
is out of the box it'll use an in-memory
database by default
and so i just need to make sure that
that's set to false otherwise it won't
bother looking at the connection string
and that's just so that people who are
on windows mac or linux they can get up
right up and running without having to
set up any kind of infrastructure
so it just makes it easier to use the
template because maybe you know the
template comes with
a sql server but you might not like sql
server maybe you're going to switch it
to um
to postgres or or to sql light or
whatever
whatever your favorite flavor is so
we've got our app settings
and so we want to now grab that
configuration so i've got a snippet for
that
okay so we can see that we're using the
configuration builder to read the app
settings file
name spaces and then we're creating a
private static variable to hold that
i guess i'll type that out by hand
should be okay okay that's not used at
the moment
and so that returns our configuration
so next we're going to wire up our
services so that's pretty easy to do
so if we go over services equals new
service collection picks up that error
i feel like someone's helping me tonight
there we go
okay and that one
and now so now what we want to do is we
want to grab startup because remember i
said
in web ui we have startup and startup
has our method configure services
and so configure services wire ups all
of the all of those services for us
and we want to reuse that we don't want
to have to write it by hand
when i first started out trying to
figure out this approach that's exactly
what i was doing but fortunately i found
a lot of great resources and i'll share
i'll share those with you at the end
so say startup
equals new startup and pass in
a configuration it needs configuration
i think that's good i'll maybe a
reference there we go
and now we could just call startup dot
configure
services and we pass in our services
and it will configure them for us that's
so good right so simple
it's all done no not really if only it
could be that easy
there is a gotcha if we were to run that
now we'd encounter an object
reference error and that's because we're
trying to register
identity services and it actually needs
a
i web host environment and so we're
going to create a mock
of iweb host environment so that we can
avoid this error altogether
and so we'll use mock for that so we
need to do that before we call configure
services so we might just do it here
so let's see services dot add
singleton oops singleton and this is
going to be
our mock and we'll put it bring in mrq
dot of i web host
environment and basically what i'm doing
is i'm just creating kind of a bare
bones mock
that will suit just the needs that
identity has
so that we can uh avoid this issue
altogether and
it took me a little while to figure this
out you know i had to actually um
troll through the asp.net core source
code um
to figure this out but i've been doing
that more and more lately so
it's been being pretty useful
environment
that's the great thing about it being
open source right we can jump in
and we can just see how it works
so the environment's going to be
development you probably could grab that
elsewhere but anyway
i'll bring in that name first because
that's quickly starting to annoy me
and then we'll say w dot application
name
and that's just going to be simply clean
testing dot web ui
i think that's all we need
okay good so now when we configure our
services and it tries to wire up
identity it's going to be able to find
our web host environment and and and
wire that up for us
so now when when our when our um
requests run through asp.net web api
they're kind of running
in a small scope they're running in a
request code
and so we kind of want to replicate that
here
so we're going to create a scope factory
that will share as a
services dot field service provider
dot get service oops
i service scope
factory looking good
um hopefully and hopefully i can get
some help there
yes peak and we'll just make that static
i would i'd like to use resharper but i
don't think my surface book can take
anymore
it's time for a new laptop
all right uh so we've got that in place
and so now
let's flesh out our helper methods um so
we'll start with a snippet for this one
save a little bit of time
okay so you can see here we're using our
scope factory to create a scope
and then using that we're able to
actually just grab the db
context
so we say scope dot service provider
which is our i
service provider dot get service
application db context
and we're able to do that because we
wire all of our services by calling
configure services
and if we look at configure services
it had some extension methods to wire up
infrastructure
and inside of infrastructure this is
where we wired up our database
okay so all of this is happening now for
us in our tests
as part of that one-time setup that
we're using
and yeah this was a big reason that i
went with n-unit i just really like
how easy it was to create integration
tests and how our needs for managing
global shared state were met by this
one-time setup
you can do it in the other frameworks
but it's not quite so easy
let's see so we've got that one in place
now we want to do our send async
and this is similar but we want to get
mediator this time
because it's going to be responsible for
sending our requests our commands or our
queries
so we'll say mediator equals scope dot
service provider dot get service
i mediated or just like that
and then we can just say await mediator
dot send
and our request which we passed in here
we want to return the result though
and that's defined by kind of the type
of request that we made so we have a i
request
of type t response and so if we're
looking at our back at our get to do's
query
you can see that it is an eye request of
type today's view model
so we could pass in a get to this query
which would return
uh today's view model and that's exactly
what we're going to do
so everything in place
i think we can run that test
there's a little bit of setup but after
that's done
uh we're good to go get to do's tests
i want to call it get to do's queries
tests
anyway it doesn't matter let's run it
control rt
so this one will take about two seconds
to run maybe a bit longer so i assume
that's going to feel like 20 minutes
so we'll just have to be patient
let's see
it fails else i have to debug it
very patient
any questions
that's okay we'll have time for
questions um at the end hopefully
and uh also we'll have time for
questions in the slack channel
afterwards
i'll be sticking around
here we go that took a long time
okay that took 15.9 seconds so obviously
the load on my system um is is more than
i expected
with with the live streaming but that's
okay we'll still be able to do this
quite easily
so this failed but it failed for any
reason we were gonna
get there eventually um
just remember to keep on mute if if you
don't mind
so what the reason that it failed is it
expected
result.list to contain one items but it
found
two and this is coming from fluent
assertions you know we're seeing those
really good
test results and those error message and
we're seeing
result.lists which was part of the
actual
variable name so it's really easy to
understand what happened so essentially
what's happening is that there was some
data already in the database
and when we ran this test it failed and
um and it was because there was just two
two items in the database and that's
simply because we're not cleaning up the
database yet
so now we need to start using respawn so
that we can clean up the database and
the way we're gonna do that
is we're going to reset the database
back to a clean state
before each test runs we could do it
after each test runs but that can be
kind of problematic
because what if the test fails to
complete and it doesn't do its cleanup
so it's better just to do it before each
test runs so let's do that now
so back to
testing dot cs
and here we go
so we're going to create a new
checkpoint and obviously that's going to
be a field
we've got a new checkpoint and that
comes from respawn so we'll bring in the
namespace for that
and create it just like that and if we
don't have any you know configuration to
provide um then that's fine but as i
mentioned earlier we're going to need to
exclude
or ignore the migrations history
table because we don't want it to wipe
that so this is expecting an array
and the table name is ef migration
history just like that
good and um
that's pretty much it i'll do one other
thing which is just
a little bit nicer we'll make sure that
the database exists
um and that it's up to date with the
latest migration so that we don't have
to deal with that
in the future and you don't have to go
and create it before you run the test
because that could get pretty annoying
so we'll just call that method ensure
database
and we'll just pop that down here so
ensure
database i should put in a few more
things there
okay now we're still
steal that and we'll steal that as well
okay and all you have to do is say
context dot
database
database dot migrate i saw a question
come up there um it's an interesting
question
and it was one of the reasons that i
went with end unit so these tests are
not running in parallel they're going to
run synchronously
because yes otherwise we'd have trouble
maintaining
the database and side effects would be
a plenty so yeah we're running them
synchronously
okay so database.migrate and i think
that's everything
now we need a method which is going to
use this checkpoint field to reset the
state
so we'll create a public static
async task reset
state and we'll say a weight
check point dot
um so so why not use transactions um so
i found this approach just to be a
little bit
a little bit cleaner a little bit easier
to manage
you could definitely you could
definitely use transactions but i wanted
to give this approach a try
and it's been working nicely for me so
the other question i saw pop up which
was cool i like how that's working
um is n unit only synchronous no
n unit can also run tests asynchronously
in parallel
but its default option is to run test
synchronously
and let's in contrast to x unit where
it's default option is to run tests
asynchronously
and and of course x unit also supports
running tests synchronously
although i had a lot of trouble getting
that to work with xunit because
it's a supported feature but i think
there's some difficulties with
x unit and maybe visual studio 2019
there's some issues on github and in
forums
and um and
uh yeah it hasn't it doesn't seem to be
solved yet so hopefully they'll solve it
soon
anyway i'll um i'll get this set up and
we'll continue on a little bit but i'll
try to come back to some of these
questions
uh as we go so we do have a lot to cover
calculation
animation dot get connection string
default connection
okay so that's going to reset our
database and it's going to reset it
based on
the default connection which is the same
connection string we're using to wire up
our db context
so now we need a test space and we're
going to use the test base to contain
our setup logic for our tests
so these are we're going to we're going
to run this logic before
we run our tests and so to do that we'll
call
setup from
from n unit there notice
and public async task
setup and we'll go await
reset state which doesn't exist but of
course we can do that because we're
going to use the using static director
so using static testing and that will
work
clean up the namespaces so that's
looking good
so now to use that all we have to do is
actually get to these test to inherit
from that
and so that will run the setup
then it will run the test and if we had
specified any kind of cleanup in the in
the test place it would have run that
too
now i'm not going to run that test
because it's going to it's going to be
a little bit slow what i'll do is i'll
complete all of the tests and we'll run
them at the end so hopefully we can um
we can see them complete successfully
but i don't want it to run for 15.9
seconds again because that was um
felt like um 60 seconds so
okay so what i want to do now is try
creating some tests for a command um and
i can see
we've got about 10 minutes left so i'll
speed it up a little bit
so i'm going to use my snippet so we can
create it with the
folders and the files
like this
okay so we're going to create it in
to-do list commands create
to do list tests
and i will grab the stubs
good and bring in the name spaces
and we'll bring in our using static
testing good
and so for the first test require
minimum fields we're going to check that
our validation is working correctly
and remember that's coming from a
pipeline behavior
um and so that behavior is going to run
before the request runs it'll validate
any request that comes through the
system
so i'll grab that
and we'll bring in reference to fluent
assertions
and the create to do list command
and the validation exception now that we
have to be careful to get the validation
exception from the clean testing
application common exceptions
because that's a custom application
exception i wrote rather than the one
that's in
system dot component model dot data
annotations
okay so what's happening here is we're
creating a new instance of the command
but we're not filling out
one of the required fields which is
title
and that's much required because we're
using fluent validation
and it's specified that it must not be
empty
back a little bit then we're using
fluent actions we're going to say
in invoking send async the command it
should throw a validation exception
so this is a good example but we really
need to flush this test out a little bit
more
it says we should require minimum fields
we probably
need to get a little bit more specific
about exactly what validation exception
was thrown
and what errors were contained in that
validation exception which is contained
in this
dictionary so there's an errors
dictionary as part of this class that
you can interrogate
and we're not going to do it for this
test but we will do it for one that's
coming up
okay so that that test is complete again
we won't run up we'll wait we'll wait
till the end to have that that fun
so now i want to write a test for
requiring a unique title
and this is another part of the
validation that's happening for this
request
we'll basically check to see if that
title already exists or not
and if the title does exist then it will
throw a validation exception
so we do that by setting up our data in
the database
first we create a new to-do list with
the title shopping
and that happens immediately using send
async then
we create the to-do list command which
will
we will use to then as part of
fluentaction.invoking
send that request and assert that it
should throw a validation exception
so again we should dig a little bit
deeper there and we will in an upcoming
example
okay and finally for the
create to-do list command this last test
should create to-do list
we're going to do a little bit more
remember that we're using asp.net core
identity
in this system well these these to-do
lists are created um
with the user id the currently logged in
user
and they're modified with the user id as
well so
if we were to run an update to do list
command and so i want to
test that as well so you can see we're
going to introduce a couple of new um
helper methods we're going to run as a
default user async
and that's basically going to create a
user in the database and give us a user
id and it's going to use
it's going to do that using asp.net core
identity
then we're going to actually
create this new list which is going to
be called tasks
we'll get the id um and then we'll find
that list
in the database so we'll introduce a new
method called find async will allow us
to
grab an entity from the database and
then we'll run our assertions
against against that that list
so the first thing we need to do is
implement these two methods
so we'll start by implementing find
async and of course we're going to do
that in our
testing helper class we'll do it just
after
actually we'll do it just before add
async
okay so you can see it's similar we grab
the db context
and then we call find async based on the
entity that was specified because it's
generic
and passing in the id and so that'll
return it if it exists
otherwise it'll return null so the other
one that we wanted to
implement was we need to bring in that
noise first
and we need to run as default user async
so let's see how we can do that so
so this this method's going to allow us
to work with a valid
user id and so i'll bring in some
snippets
and we'll have a look at those
we will add these after the database
stuff
maybe maybe just here
okay so you can see there's two methods
we're using runner's default user async
and all that does is just specify um
some dummy data for a user to create so
there's a
a username and a password and so then in
run as user async it takes that username
and password
grabs the scope and it grabs the user
manager from asp.net core identity
and the application user is how our
users are defined it's the identity user
so now you can see we're creating a new
instance of the application user
using the username as both the username
and the email
we're making that request to user
manager so we're creating that user
specifying the application user and the
password
and that if if successful will return us
a new user id
and so we're going to store that as a
static field
so that we can access it as needed
now remember that we're also resetting
the start state of the database before
each test
and so that means that this user is
going to be cleaned up before each test
so we also need to when we reset the
state of the database
just set that to null so we'll do that
here
there we go
i think that is everything oh yes
there's one more thing we need to do so
we're using an i current user service to
get the current user
and that's um that exists in the
application layer
and it's used by any request that would
like to get the user id of the current
user
the current implementation for that is
in web ui
um and it requires a valid http context
but we're not doing asp.net core
integration testing so we're going to
create a mock
for the icurrent user service instead
and that mock
is just going to return the current user
id um
if it's if it's set to a value and and
and um you know
whether whether it's set to a value on
or not really um
so the way we have to do that is we have
to actually remove the existing
registration of our current user service
and then add a new registration for
testing
and we'll use mock to create that
registration
just as we did with the iweb host
environment
so i'm going to pop that in right here
uh no i'm not that would be a bad place
to put it we need to do it after
configure services because that's where
the um web ui version is going to be
registered
so we replace the service registration
for the i current user service
in link and we
we do that by first finding the current
user service descriptor
we can then remove it from the from the
services collection
and then we can register a new one as i
current user service
and it sets it up so that user id will
be equal to static
current user id
okay so that's it with that in place
those tests would all run and um i
should say you know the tests are
running slow tonight um but that's just
because of
the live stream now i've got about 18
tests on the
clean architecture template that is more
added all the time and they run in about
1.8 seconds so about 100 milliseconds
per test which is pretty amazing
considering we're wiring up all of these
services we're programming against a
live database
so it's pretty great so that is done
so i wanted to create uh one more set of
tests just the
update to do list tests um
and then i think we'll we'll run those
tests um
and and and provide a summary
so the update to do list tests we can
put in
um this here update to do this test.cs
and i've got a snippet so that we don't
have to jump through hoops
now this is this is um has some similar
logic to what we've covered in the
create
to-do list but of course it goes into a
little bit of detail and showing
hey we need to set these things up ahead
of time because we're not going to be
dealing with this global state
so i'll paste that in and we'll bring in
the name spaces
here's a handy hint if you're not using
resharper if i hit ctrl
a ctrl x to cut it ctrl v to paste it
jumping through hoops right then i can
press alt enter
and add missing using it's hard to see
it's down the bottom here
it'll go ahead and add all those usings
in for me just kind of nice
there we go we'll clean that up so
that'll be ready to
run uh so that's simple so you know
we're seeing
these tests now they're easy to
create they're going to be easy to
maintain
and they're also easy to understand so
they're going to provide system
documentation for the
for the users who come along and they're
testing a whole lot
and in testing that much it's going to
give us great confidence that we can
deploy these changes to production
so what i'm going to do is i'll run all
of these tests
uh and we'll we'll do a little bit of a
wrap up and we'll come back and just see
if they pass so hopefully
hopefully you get to see that now i'm
also going to check in these changes
so you'll be able to access the sample
repo as soon as this
presentation is finished
so wrapping up resources so first and
foremost there's the clean testing demo
code
so this is where i'm going to post the
demonstration code
the repo is already there it's in its
initial state where we started tonight
and i'll do a commit that's at the end
of this presentation
there's also the clean architecture
solution template
and so if you wanted a even more test
then you can just go
net new ca solution from the command
line and that will bring
those up for you now the next two
resources
contoso university by jimmy bogart and
fixie demo by patrick loy
were a major source of inspiration for
this approach
now you have three really cool resources
you've got the clean architecture
solution template
which is using n-unit you've got the
contoso university sample
which is using x unit and you've got the
fixie demo which of course is using fixy
and they all have something a little bit
different in them
so there's good things to learn so i
recommend you check them all out but
um the other point to make is that you
know it doesn't matter
which framework you're using what your
preferred framework is
now you have a good example of any of
these approaches so
hopefully you'll be able to get started
so let's do a quick summary so tonight
i've shown you clean tests that are
simple to create
maintain and understand these tests were
configured to run against production
services against a real database
and helped to pro and helped with
verification testing tools such as mock
and fluent assertions improved our
simplicity and productivity
and we used respawn to reset the
database state back to a clean state
before each test was run
and it gave us a knowing a known
starting point for each test
now this approach results in a better
test coverage
and higher confidence so before we cut
re
finish up there let's just see if those
tests all succeeded that's good i'm very
glad about that
so yeah we've got seven passing tests it
took about 8.5 seconds which is
which is super slow um but that's okay
when you run it for yourself
you're going to see that these tests run
really quick so we're no longer
constrained by that pyramid
we can write with modern technologies
modern tools modern approach
we can write these tests that run fast
and give us super high confidence
so the confidence to deploy your system
to production knowing that it will
behave
as expected that's it for me
stay safe and keep testing thank you
so i'll be heading over to the slack
room now and we can we can continue that
conversation